all right thank you thanks for inviting
me so this is uh joint work in in three
parts with uh fares hadayati who was a
phd student here he's now at odesk uh
partly with valtakula and alan malik who
are
in front row over here and the third
part is with bauter and alan and aj
takimoto and manfred warmuth
all right so
i'm talking here about
prediction games where you know we play
a
repeated game with an adversary
and we're aiming to predict something in
the case of of a discrete set of
outcomes at each round
we make some prediction from so we call
that a t that's our action at time t
from an action set a
the adversary chooses some outcome
yt from a set y and we incur
we the player incurred a lot
a loss that depends on our action and
the and the actual outcome so we could
think about the briar loss which is this
squared euclidean distance between our
prediction and the and the outcome uh
for instance if we're in a vector space
and that's one of the losses that we'll
consider okay we keep on going in this
way round after round and the aim is
that at the end of it all
we have a small regret so the sum of the
losses that we've incurred along the way
is not too much bigger than the
best we could have done in retrospect
for that particular sequence of of
outcomes
okay and you know we may do something a
little more complicated where rather
than thinking about the infimum over
the set of actions we had to choose from
we have some different comparison class
potentially smaller comparison class
that we're competing with
okay so they're the kinds of problems
that i'm going to consider here
so you know these universal prediction
problems
completely deterministic they're making
very weak assumptions on the process
generating the data so that's one of the
really appealing things about
understanding prediction
uh prediction games or game theory
formulations of prediction problems
and it means that if you are in a
probabilistic setting then you know you
can use
uh effective methods for for these
problems to uh
to successfully solve probabilistic
problems so you're kind of getting at
the deterministic heart of a decision
problem uh and in many cases you know
they're they're
closely related to
to standard statistical methods and you
can view the positive results in this
setting as
strong robustness properties of those
methods in this talk i want to talk
about specifically the case where we we
can actually
efficiently compute optimal strategies
so we're playing
the best uh possible at every step along
the way so
you know that's something that
of course such a thing exists but the
cases that i want to talk about are
cases where they're things that can be
efficiently computed
okay so
just to
add a bit more detail to that so the
regret is the quantity of interest right
it's the sum of our losses versus the
best we could have done in retrospect
and we're interested in playing
the player does the best it can the
adversary has best response and so on
all the way through for t rounds of this
game
and that
alternating in
sequence of this regret is the value of
the game and the game's
specified by the loss function
the outcome space
y and and our action space a
and a strategy is a mapping from what
we've seen
already the sequence of outcomes to our
choice of the actions
uh and so we can think of this inf supe
the the if there we could think of as
just you know for a given strategy we've
seen this sequence of outcomes y one
through t minus one uh and then we make
some choice of what's the what's the
right action to play
and so a minimax optimal strategy is the
mapping that actually achieves the value
of the game
um minimizes over strategies the maximum
over those sequences of outcomes okay so
we want to know you know what's the
mini-max regret what's an optimal
player's strategy an optimal adversary
strategy when are these things
efficiently computable in particular
and
how do they depend on the various
characteristics of the game on the loss
function and we'll look at several cases
i'll tell you about these in a moment
and the various
you know parameters that specify the
game the outcome space and the action
space
all right so this is the outline of the
talk i want to look at
you know how we can compute these
minimax optimal strategies it's just a
you know simple dynamic programming sort
of formulation of it conceptually very
simple but we're interested in cases
where we can actually efficiently
compute those solutions first part is
all about log loss so closely related to
the last the last few a couple of talks
closely related to this universal
compression
idea
the second part is about euclidean loss
and i'll probably skip over
some of the details of that and the
third part is looking at a fixed design
linear regression game
okay so minimax optimal strategies
that's the value of the game we saw a
moment ago and we can easily write a
recursion for that right once we've seen
all t outcomes then you know that
specifies the second term there in the
regret the best we could have done
and
then we can just iterate backwards doing
this min of our our choice max of the
the adversary's choice of loss plus the
value to go one step further right so we
iterate that backwards and that gives us
when we have seen no outcomes that gives
us the value of the gain
okay so you know what we're interested
in is that recursion in particular you
know the
what's the minimizing action for any
particular sequence of uh past outcomes
so for any history
so to play the minimax strategy we just
need to compute that value function
and then find the minimizing action the
one that
given the
adversary's best response minimizes this
this loss plus value to go
um of course that's hard because there
are many different
histories that we might be faced with
right so this value function is a
typically very complicated beast whoops
and so the question is you know when can
we efficiently compute the value
function and typically it's it's a
function of some
compact summary of the history that
we've seen so far i'm saying typically
in the cases where we can efficiently
compute it i guess
okay so
um
i'll probably skip over skip over this
so there are there's a small set of
prediction games let me
zip past this there we go
small set of prediction games where we
can efficiently compute the optimal
strategy what i'm going to talk about in
this talk is uh the case related to to
universal compression log loss uh and
and some results we have there for for
cases that
um uh
uh where simpler strategies are optimal
uh the quadratic loss so the the game
that the nice uh cartoon at the start
illustrated
that was valtter's artwork by the way
and the
linear regression case um so this
adversarial formulation of fixed design
linear regression
okay so that's the agenda i want to
start with log loss
um
so here you can think of this as a
sequential probability estimation
problem
uh where we're
looking at the sequential
adversarial form of or deterministic
form of you know minimizing kl
divergence right so we make a prediction
that's a probability distribution
i guess a density strictly speaking at
density with respect to some measure
okay the cases we saw in the previous
two talks were with respect to the
counting measure
and we pay a cost that's the negative
log of our predicted density of the
outcome that we see
and
uh you know the regret of course is just
this difference of the uh log
probabilities
um for the for the so difference of
of two likelihoods a maximum likelihood
and a um
log likelihoods i'm sorry maximum uh log
likelihood and and the sequence of
predicted uh densities
okay so first observation these
strategies are always uh can always be
viewed as as joint densities right so
given a history the the
previous
sequence of outcomes y1 through yt
if we have a
mapping from those histories to
densities on y well then we can just
multiply those up to give us a joint
density
right so every strategy is just a joint
uh distribution
on outcomes
uh and then the regret is just a log
likelihood ratio right it's the
maximum log likelihood versus
log of our
predicted joint
density
okay um
so you know these these sorts of
problems have a have a big history um
you can view them as sequential
probability prediction they're
equivalent to
this this notion of uh sequential uh
universal uh uh data compression uh or
you know there are there are um very
closely related repeated gambling or
investment problems for the same long
history in in in several different uh
communities
okay and the optimal strategy is known
it's normalized maximum likelihood it's
been known since the 80s so what you do
is every strategy is a joint
distribution the optimal strategy for a
game of length t
is
assigns a joint probability to a
sequence of outcomes that is
proportional to the the maximum
likelihood
okay so you just look at
for any any sequence y1 through yt you
can compute the maximum likelihood and
and then you're going to have to have
some normalizing factor
uh and that that gives you the joint
distribution
and uh stuck off showed this was optimal
a long time ago very simple
proof that involves showing that every
sequence
has equal regret for this strategy and
so
anything that that doesn't equalize
regret necessarily has some sequence for
which its regret is larger
and so how would you actually use this
this is a joint distribution that that's
specified so you have to go and you know
compute conditional distribution so you
know we've seen some history y1 through
yt minus 1 and we want to compute the
conditional distribution of y t given
that past so we're integrating out the
the things beyond t or beyond t minus
one um and uh and and that's the
computation we have to do and you know
that's
that's a a big integral
and you know the question
that i want to look at in this part of
the talk is you know when can you do
something that's computationally cheaper
but but still optimal i guess maybe
that's the wrong way of saying it when
is when is
computing these integrals actually the
wrong way to compute the
the optimal strategy because normalized
maximum likelihood is the unique optimal
strategy and the two cases that that i
want to look at are
versions of nml where we
act as if
we're at the last step and so the
integration that we need to do here is
just over a single
a single future outcome so it's a
simpler thing
and the other cases is a bayesian
strategy
so the first of these is sequential nml
right so this is where we pretend that
this is the last prediction so it's just
you know we've seen t minus one things
and we act as if
our next step is the very last one and
we do the optimal thing as if that was
the what would be the optimal thing if
that were the case which is nml
and
so the conditional calculation then is
just this this integration over a single
single outcome
um and and you know that's known to have
an asymptotically optimal regret um but
what i'm interested in here is when is
it actually optimal
so
you know the the punch line is that it's
um
it's optimal precisely when
this sequential normalized maximum
likelihood viewed as a uh stochastic
process is exchangeable right which
means you can switch around the order of
the
the order of the the indices and you get
exactly the same
density
so
so exchangeability of this
stochastic process is
is equivalent to that being the optimal
um
uh the optimal
uh prediction strategy um you know that
means you can ignore the horizon right
act as if you're about to to finish the
game after the next step
and i'll skip over the proof there
it involves this this equalizer property
for for nml
pretty straightforward
so
the other class of strategies that
i wanted to
say something about his bayesian
strategies um
we have some prior distribution pi
on our uh our model
and uh and the bayesian strategy assigns
a joint distribution that's just the um
the expectation under that prior of the
the
density
and of course you know we have the nice
bayesian machinery right we can
sequentially update our prior given one
more piece of information we just
multiply whatever the prior has become
you know
the previous prior by the likelihood to
get the posterior so that's
again a
you know
a simple simple update i want to
highlight the
so jeffrey's prior is going to feature
here
the jeffries prior is is the one that's
proportional to the square root of the
determinant of the fischer information
and that's something that
has been widely studied um
you know it's
it has
uh attractive properties including the
fact that you can change the
parameterization it doesn't change the
the distribution
so this is something that just pops up
it turns out you know we'll see in a
moment this is the right prior
and you know there are various
asymptotic optimality results for for
prediction with with uh jeffrey's prior
um
okay so
here's the the main theorem and i'm i'm
sweeping some conditions under the rug
here but but in the case where the
maximum likelihood estimator
has an asymptotic normality property
then
you have equivalence of all of the
following statements so the first two we
saw earlier right that ignoring the
horizon
leaves you with a an optimal strategy
precisely when this sequential nml is
an exchangeable stochastic process
but turns out that's that means that
you're in a situation where you could
also compute the normalized maximum
likelihood the optimal strategy using a
bayesian strategy right and their
equivalent any bayesian strategy um you
know turns out has to be a bayesian
strategy with
with jeffrey's prior uh and same thing
can be said for sequential uh nml
so you know jeffrey's prior is it um uh
you know this is telling us that if we
can ignore the time horizon then still
be optimal then we should
that's the same as doing a bayesian
prediction with jeffrey's prior and and
jeffrey's prior is is essential here and
jeffrey's prior really arises
i mean in two words it arises because
you know the asymptotics pop out because
we've got this this property uh of
exchangeability means we can go off to
infinity and and the asymptotic
normality is what what makes jeffrey's
prior the right thing in this setting
okay
so
uh
i'll skip over so we can characterize
one-dimensional exponential families um
uh that have this property oh and by the
way you know they they exclude the the
bernoulli case right that we've seen
before jeffrey's prior in the bernoulli
case won't won't do
um okay so uh
the second part of the talk is on
euclidean
uh loss so this is a game where we're
working in a vector space and we pay
we the the loss is the squared euclidean
distance between our prediction and the
outcome
times a constant factor
and and the adversary is constrained to
some set in
rd
the regret is the the same old thing and
uh i guess
i'm pretty much going to just state the
state the main result so this this blue
green shape is our is our uh outcome
space this is the set that the adversary
is restricted to uh it's hard to see
here this is the center of the smallest
ball that contains that set
and it has a certain radius and the
point is
the main result is that for any closed
bounded set
the minimax strategy depends only on the
center of that smallest ball
the the optimal regret depends only on
its radius
and the optimal strategy in this case
is given a sequence of n outcomes
so far you take the sample average of
those
and take a mixture of that with the
center so you're shrinking towards the
center at a very precisely you know a
prescribed
rate you shrink towards the center
and that's your prediction
and the optimal regret
depends on the radius of this smallest
ball
uh and on these these coefficients the
alphas and you know there's a specific
form for the alphas um so this is always
a number less than one
uh
and looks
uh rather like
one over n
and
and that gives a regret that looks
rather like log
log t
okay and i'm gonna skip it so that you
know there's the specific form for the
for the coefficients alpha
so i'm going to skip over some of these
details similar sorts of ideas pop up in
the
in the linear regression case which i
want to get to
um
so
and just say you know the
high level idea of the proof is that you
know we can always find uh a simplex of
of contact points that that kind of
constrain this smallest ball
right and and uh stop it from getting
any smaller in some sense so that's a
subset of our of our set y for that
subset you know the regret um is this
big and and so
uh the regret for our original set is at
least that big
since this is a
subset of the adversary's constraint set
and we can look from the other side at
this at this smallest ball that's a
superset
and it has exactly the same same regret
so that's a big picture idea of of the
quadratic case
okay so
and you know this thing grows
like log t and you can get the second
order terms and you know if you look at
things it's like it's like a constant
factor that we're that we're buying here
you know this looks like a a constant
factor this is the simplex case
okay so let me get on to the
the uh online linear regression problem
so here
you know this is this is a
square loss again but it's a it's a
regression setting so we have this side
information right so we're talking the
protocol is you know we've we've got the
length of the game is fixed in advance
the set of covariate vectors is fixed in
advance so it's a fixed design linear
regression problem
and
and there's some constraints set you
know constraining what the adversary can
can
provide to us as the the labels the real
value labels
and uh the protocol is for each round of
the game
we make a prediction of what the the
value
yt will be and the adversary reveals it
and uh has to satisfy this this
constraint these constraints right that
the sequence y1 through yt
um uh satisfies some some constraints
i'll say a little about different
constraints in a moment
and then we incur a loss that's just the
squared difference between our
prediction and the actual outcome
okay so it's a sequential
fixed design linear regression of a sort
of a game and the comparison class here
is you know we're allowed to predict
any any real number but we're competing
with the best
linear
prediction
right so so this is a least squares
comparison comparison
okay so um you know what would we do if
we were in a probabilistic setting
where we see for instance um
uh fixed design and the y's come from a
linear model with uncorrelated errors
mean zero uncorrelated errors we do
ordinarily squares right
so you know given this
sequence of x y pairs
we'd estimate the parameter by taking
our design matrix x take x transpose x
to the minus 1 times x transpose y right
that's our estimate for the for the
parameter vector
and we plug that in for each
x to be our prediction so in an online
or a sequential setting you know we
might do something of this flavor
right we'd take maybe the x transpose x
for the points that we've seen
uh already
and and the corresponding
x transpose y and use that for our
estimate maybe we would regularize this
in some way
so you know i just wanted to pop those
up as a reminder of what ordinary least
squares look like so this is ridge
regression if we added some
regularization term then we'd be
shrinking our parameters in
in different directions
um so it turns out
subject has some constraints right so
the adversary has
these values yt constrained to
um uh to have you know absolute value
smaller than some bound
um
the optimal strategy turns out uses some
simple sufficient statistics let's
consider this sum of y t times x t
um
and uh the minimap strategy is linear so
it's very much the flavor of least
squares it's this
to predict
y n plus one we use x n plus one
transpose times some matrix c n plus one
times this
analog of x transpose y so far where the
c's are
you know we take into account the x t x
d transposes so far and we also take
into account the future ones with a very
precisely
prescribed
weighting
right using these so this is a recursive
definition of the of the cts
um
and you know you can compute the maximin
distribution as well has the same
expectation uh you can compute the value
to go and it's quadratic in these in
this state also includes you know a
second order term involving the sum of
the squares
um
okay and there's a little fine print
here right so these bounds that we have
can't we can't too tightly constrain our
adversary right otherwise
making a linear prediction like this uh
you know it's if the adversary is too
tightly constrained then we should be
making some some clipped prediction and
then our value to go becomes a very
complex function and you know so these
are the cases satisfying these
conditions
are the cases where we can come up with
an easy to compute value to go
okay so they're a little strange those
conditions
say two words about those in a moment
but
so we're in this in the box constraint
case
one thing i wanted to point out so we we
get that the regret looks like this
quantity
in terms of these x transpose c x
uh
values
and they're what arise in here right so
if we think about this as being an
analog of ridge regression where we have
some shrinkage that's in every direction
what we're adding in here is shrinkage
that's in a direction that's hedging
against future
values of these
future directions
and the amount of shrinkage depends on
the contribution to regret that we're
going to see from these future future
x's
okay so the term that you know each of
these terms
i'm sorry
um so uh so you know you can think of
that as the the the optimal shrinkage
that arises analogous to to you know the
um
is this a constraint on nature or
b is a constraint on nature the
algorithm doesn't need to know b
right
um so actually and if you think about it
you know this is saying that the y y t
in absolute value is smaller than b t
um and and there's a condition that says
you know those constraints can't be too
tight on the adversary
but actually you know the adversary
should be pushing yt out to to maintain
this constraint so let's
so you know the natural thing to
consider is what happens if you impose
an ellipsoid kind of constraint of
exactly that sort right so think about
um uh constraining the adversary in this
way where the the sequences is
constrained
uh to so that that sum satisfies a an
inequality of this kind and it turns out
you know the the optimal strategy there
is the same thing
and the minimax regret is exactly this
upper bound
has even a stronger property that we
have an equalizer property that the
regret of this strategy for every
sequence
is equal to
the sum of the y squared x transpose cx
so if in particular if you're on the
surface of the ellipsoid every every
sequence has exactly that regret
which is kind of striking and analogous
to to what happens in the log loss case
you know it's normalized
um maximum likelihood case
all right so um
the strategy doesn't need to know the
constraints you know there are several
open problems the most obvious one is
how can we move away from the fixed um
the fixed design
setting all right so you know what
happens if we know if we're in a analog
of a transduction setting right so we
know the x1 through xt but we don't know
what order it's going to be presented in
and you know we'd like to understand how
to do things outside the fixed design
setting as well
right thank you
um
right i mean so you could you could
define you you could come up with
sufficient conditions for for that i
mean all we really need is that we get
asymptotic normality
right so you know it could be and under
these weak conditions that imply you
know the weak sort of regularity
conditions are classical things
i remember
well the first thing i
that looks like that was
no so they were interested specifically
in getting these
you know optimality in cases where um
where the specific strategies we
consider are not optimal you know you
don't have
uh the bayesian with with uh jeffrey's
prior being being optimal and and so
they're they're looking at you know how
you can make these small changes near
the edge of near the edge of the simplex
i mean very much like the last the last
so you know different different kind of
issue we're looking at where we can
actually compute that